what's up guys lunch money time Monday
morning while Wall Street's trying to
get rich the rest of us just trying to
get our lunch money right I'm here with
the beautiful Miss Polina she's got a
sailor outfit on today what does that
look like a striped shirt looks like a
sailor outfit to me it's better than
being in a prison jumpsuit though so
let's get into the topics and let's have
some education what's going on
Apple is delaying the mass production of
their 2020 flagship iPhone unclear
whether that means that you won't be
able to buy it in September like you
normally can do you normally upgrade I
don't what you do well I'd like a four I
do it cuz I'm on the plan unless you
upgrade every so often I feel like the
iPhone gets a little bit better each
time but like if you got a iPhone you
get an iPhone yeah but you wouldn't
would you judge me if I have three no
really no I mean your pictures would
suck but like other than that like the
camera I feel like is the biggest thing
that changes for most people right and
today's society where we're all taking
selfies do we know when they're gonna
try to come back online well they're
gonna start production in July I think
okay so me it'll be delayed by a couple
of months yeah well the big news about
Apple is that they have so much cash
that it won't really affect them
financially like it's not like they're
close to insolvency but this is
obviously one of their largest revenue
drivers ya know it's it's huge so are
you gonna upgrade even if there's like
lines and you have to wait and I don't
wait in lines I just wait until everyone
gets all the hype over I also don't
upgrade the software immediately oh yeah
you don't do that why is that because
whenever they do it Lots and there's
like little bugs and stuff and so I let
them work out all the kinks and then I
step in and say okay now I'm ready for
the other I read the internet and I got
all kinds of smart things I'm doing okay
General Motors is finally this morning
announcing that they are going to
suspend their dividend and their stock
buyback program as many people know auto
sales have basically fallen off a cliff
in the United States they've shut down
all their plan
and so they need to conserve cash do you
understand why they're suspending the
dividend so they can conserve cash I got
a genius on my hands so here comes the
dilemma so they shut down in mid-march
all the car manufacturers shut down
their plants and they thought okay we'll
be shut down for two or three weeks then
we'll come back but then they had to
fire a bunch of employees they put a
bunch on furlough and they also did pay
cuts for a lot of people and that was
all to conserve cash that cash in the
balance sheet but now they're realizing
wait a second this may be a longer issue
than we thought so they're gonna suspend
the dividend and also not do the stock
buybacks but if you're a shareholder
there's people who were depending on or
waiting on that dividend so there should
be cell pressure on the stock now so but
wasn't that your big issue with the
airlines like the stock buybacks weren't
you like slamming them for that and
you're like Wesley oh no and now you're
like oh well that's for the shareholder
well of course but like the whole point
of a business is to survive right the
rule the first rule of business is you
have to survive the second rule is then
you get to thrive but if you don't
survive then there's no point in having
the business and so exactly what they're
doing is exactly what the airline should
have done right a second that you
realize that there's cash issues then
you need to conserve cash so what the
airline's did was they used in many
cases estimations over 90 percent of
their free cash flow rather than put it
into the bank account right and hold on
to it for a rainy day they spot back
their stock which is delivering value
back to shareholders but now all of a
sudden they're sitting there and they're
saying wait a second we don't have any
money
we'll go back to your shareholders and
get the money so what GM is basically
doing is they're saying we're not gonna
give them away to shareholders right now
because we need it for the business
right and also we're not gonna use it to
buy back our stock right which is
another way to deliver value back to the
shareholders we're gonna use it for the
business they also have a very big
credit line that they're going to extend
and probably draw down on them as well
so they're basically they're trying to
get as much cash on the balance sheet as
possible so they have as much liquidity
to deal with whatever happens do you
think that more companies should suspend
dividends yeah
and if you're a long-term on the on the
company why not you're gonna hold it
anyway the whole key is cash is king
right right as long as you have the
liquidity then you've got all these
different options you can do all kinds
of different things or a is oxygen whoa
where did that come from
I've been reading stuff so I'm reading
the Internet to tell them what uh what
yesterday we're sitting on the couch and
clean up randomly looks over to me and
hits me with a two liner which was
literally out of nowhere she just looks
at me I look up I guess we would get
money get paid and I don't know why I
was just watching it and I was like I
think I think I want to say get money
obtain a where did that come from
literally no it was like where'd you
read that
it was like it was in my brain it's true
get money get paid whatever all right
speaking of getting paid what's going on
with kim yo-jong we talk about Kim let's
talk about Kim drunk
sorry there's a lot of Kim Kim use owns
Jones so Kim Jong Un's right now and
people are saying he's in critical
condition after a botched heart surgery
but North Korea came out and said he is
alive and well I think that they're
saying he's dead I don't think they're
saying the easy critical audition well
North Korea saying he's just fine yeah
but how did they prove that he's fine
well he's probably gonna make like a
public appearance so they you know can
say like look he's fine no they today or
yesterday they showed a letter that he
wrote like I could write a letter about
you if you were dead and say oh she's
behind like here's the letter that I
wrote no instead what I would do is I
would do like the weekend at Bernie's
behad guy dude once money be like she's
just being quiet today no problem hey
[Music]
but like okay so anyway so people are
speculating that they're like who else
who would succeed Kim jong-un and his
sister if you remember kim yo-jong you
saw her at the olympics and then all
these means of her kind of like lurking
around
supposedly she's a ruthless she's well
people say I don't know anything but
she's supposedly ruthless and she's his
closest confidant but there's a big
thing do you think that North Korea can
have a female leader one yes - if he
dies I think that she will be the leader
and three what's scary is that she
actually may be more ruthless than him
well that's what all the reports are how
do you know anything as I've read the
internet but if that is true you've got
to imagine like a lot of the things that
North Korea has done has been really
really bad mm-hmm like what else can
they do what are they gonna start doing
like like countrywide genocide or like
you know I mean there's all kinds of
stuff that they could go do and it's
just really scary to think about if the
person that most think is one of the
worst brutal dictators in the world dies
he could be replaced by somebody's
ignores or somebody better but the a
place for kim yo-jong just like i had
hope for Bob C from Disney night I can't
I can't say I have hope for anything in
North Korea but could a woman lead North
Korea and most people say no because so
it's likely that her husband's dad would
be the successor because he's a man and
he was in the military or they think a
military coup might occur no do you know
what that is
yeah when military takes over yeah yeah
I don't know listen crazy she's happened
in North Korea
supposedly kim jeong-hoon had heart
surgery some people say he's in a
vegetative state some people say that
he's absolutely fine
some people say that he's dead all I
know is I would not want to be a heart
surgeon who was involved in any of this
because you pretty much you live in
North Korea and if you killed the leader
by accident that's not gonna end so okay
so if I was to be gone who would succeed
me on lunch money oh we would have no
problem finding a co-host all we would
need is somebody to sit here and laugh
no problem well if you weren't here
there would be no success or it would
just be me and it would be Carol Baskin
gifts
tick tock videos cats Oh Max and kittens
so you just have a video like everyone
else does on the internet with a bunch
of
that's memes and gifts elevated speaking
of that's what's gonna want the crazy
topic this crazy pets
okay what is crazy pets so crazy pets so
okay so there are all these reports of
these people working from home during
quarantine and their pets like going
ballistic
like this woman will roll out her yoga
mat and the cat would just attack the
yoga mat every time what the hell is
going on with my pet and the reason do
you want to guess why pets are going
crazy well no my question was gonna be
are there reports that everyone's
working from home or is it that it's a
known fact that everyone's working from
home alright why is the cat going crazy
at the yoga mat nope basically they're
finding research finds that your pet can
sense your anxiety if you just lost your
job or if you're anxious about life and
it can you know you it can channel that
affinity and go insane the pets are
getting the anxiety from their owners
and then the pets are getting anxious
yes and then freaking out yes okay you
have dogs you know how they are yeah
they got three things they want to go to
the bathroom they want to eat food and
they want to go run around outside
that's literally it he makes them crazy
he'll be like do you want to sing and
then they get super loud Oh Oh sometimes
I've convinced my dogs that I'm the big
dog in the in the relationship and so
what I'll do is I'll start howling like
oh and it all said those who are making
the same noise and then we're all saying
that we're just howling like a pack of
dogs and then we go back to I'm the
human and they're dogs and then they're
like [ __ ] but that's fine speaking of
crazy pets last night oh that's not
really pets but do you know what he made
me watch you in your watch the top 10
most amazing moments and animal kingdom
well first of all we were watching
videos there's talking chimpanzees
there's literally chimps that can sit
and they press buttons and they can talk
because the buttons are correlated with
words so like you press a button and
then the Machine spits out and says food
or
you know lettuce or whatever and they
can put together sentences so they can
talk to humans and then one of the
suggested videos next to it on YouTube
was like top 10 moments in nature's
history or something and we clicked on
it and we saw a polar bear trying to eat
a guy in a cage in the Antarctica then
once that we see we see when we saw the
Penguins fight back against a bird and
then we saw a lion surrounded by a pack
of hyenas and all this started because
when I put on my face mask he said that
I'd look like a chimpanzee
she does she literally a chimpanzee
because you told me that chimps can't
talk or act like human no I said chimps
are the closest relative to humans they
are that's true do you know the
difference between a chimp in a gorilla
gorillas are further from humans yeah
and also you know what gorillas do the
chimps don't they beat their chests you
know do you want to know why do you want
to know why gorillas are not as
celebrate' eyes as as other animals and
lions and tigers because it was Carol
[ __ ] back all right what else we got
lunch money winner somebody won cash
cash money $100 lots of you took the URL
last week and you tweeted it use the
hashtag you guys are great listeners who
who won
Michael Michael at Morty three eight
three seven three five one two Morty I
had to check real quick to see if that
was your phone number or not just gonna
give you a call say what's up man like
the old school you know contest but
we've deemed you please respond to the
DM so we can send you the hundred
dollars any words
well I ain't liked this one because he
was really kind and he understands the
importance of sticking up for the little
guy do you stick up for the little guy
always really yeah because you look like
a chimpanzee with your mask on
that's the whole point because well
while she's trying to get rich the rest
of us just trying to get a lunch money
right that is literally what is going to
be the feeling coming out of all of this
if you were gonna turn around they're
gonna look at the banks the financial
system and government they're gonna say
those people didn't help us jim cramer
by the way we didn't put this as a topic
Jim Cramer this morning straight-up
meltdown on CNBC freaking out every day
pretty much but listen to this he was a
huge proponent of the payer paycheck
protection program and was saying how
it's so great that the government's
gonna get relief now he's saying I was a
proponent of this but this is absolute
garbage it's nonsense because over 200
public companies got the money they had
eight hundred million bucks
I think only like three or four men
giving the money back about 70 million
dollars
there's a guy in Texas his name is Morty
actually I think look look him up he's a
billionaire in Texas no I know look up
this guy he's a billionaire in Texas he
owns a bunch of hospitality industry
just type in billionaire yeah Morty it
and he'll come up and he owns a bunch of
hospitality things his company's got
like two or three MC his name I think is
literally Mortimer but they call him
Morty
he got hundreds of millions of dollars
from the payroll protection program in
the stimulus and recently he he gave a
donation to the administration he got
all of the stimulus money and he owns
this huge channeling as a multi-billion
dollar company but each one of the
individual hotels applied for the PPP so
he filed over a hundred loan
applications and he got a bunch of them
and so he's sitting there saying he's
not gonna get the money back right and
so like what ends up happening is
anybody who stands up to the social
pressure it's gonna get really bad
really fast
yeah that's cancel culture like
billionaires aren't ready for canceled
culture on the internet they just
they're just not built to deal with that
they can't deal with the PR nightmare
yeah agree yeah all right what final
words do you have for the people we
finish a fast today I feel like we went
real fast real informative couple of
jokes in there we have to say to the
people um tell him that I don't look
like a sailor you literally
we put a hat on you you we would all
call you captain Polina no problem all
right guys
Wall Street's trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get our lunch
money right we appreciate you watching
we're trying to get better about
bringing this to you right at noon and
we will talk to you tomorrow